together we are strong cry trade
unionists in Libreville many here angry
with government like gustav eager seller
who is representing the health union
here expensive stadiums were built for
the Africa Cup of Nations yet civil
servants salaries will soon be reduced
sit in sarcasm duper Seto you don't
think that sarcasm they haven't been any
schools hospitals or universities built
for seven years they can't finance
medicine in the hospitals how can we
support the Africa Cup that's why this
Africa Cup wasn't welcome here it's an
insult to the people in Gabon after the
elections of August 2016 riots broke out
the opposition spoke of electoral fraud
while their supporters set fire to the
Parliament building Ali Bongo in office
since 2009 won a narrow victory Vong
goats father previously ruled the
country for almost forty two years
government security forces attacked
opposition headquarters the violence
claimed the lives of dozens of people
signs of violence are visible all over
this building bullet holes in walls and
windows the opposition is blaming
government forces for the violence also
we would have liked to ask the
government a couple of questions about
it but nobody was ready to talk to us
Gabon is in crisis both politically and
economically oil income has been poor
yet millions have been invested in the
Africa Cup the stadium's have been half
empty for many games despite that the
Confederation of African football sees
no reason to criticize the host nation
the Gabonese people are our fan of
football when you talk about fan you
cannot relate that or linked it simply
to the opposition or make it a political
talk people attending in stadiums they
tend not only because they might not
attend not only because the price is low
or high it has to do also with the
transport facilities or configuration of
the stadium's cabins trade unionists
want to call strikes even after the
Africa Cup they're known as being close
to the opposition a thorn in the
government's side their members are
frequently arrested despite that they
want to keep going if you can afford to
stage in Africa Cup says Gustavo Gisela
you can afford to put money into the
health system
[Music]